The Association [Between] the great irish writer Samuel Beckett and the game of cricket
Deserves to Be more Widely Known he
Was A fine Player when a student at Trinity College Dublin and Even Married to Mention in A famous
Wisdoms The Cricketers Bible the only Nobel Prize Winner to be so lauded on One Occasion in the Mid-1960s
Beckett Travelled From Paris To London to Watch the Test Match between England and Australia it was [a] beautiful Sunny summer Afternoon
Blue Skies Lord's Cricket Ground [Green] and Glorious One of his Friends Remarked
What A wonderful day this is A sort of day that Would Make you glad to be alive
- Which Beckett Responded dryly, I, wouldn't go as far as that
The Story Nicely Encompasses Two aspects of Samuel Beckett his Famously Bleak view of life and his
mordant Sense of Humor if as Horace Walpole
Remarked The World Is a comedy to those who think and a tragedy to those who feel it is fitting that beckett's Waiting for godot
Is subtitled a tragic Comedy in his Theatrical Images and Prose writings Beckett achieve Despair beauty [and]
Articulation of Human Suffering Shot Through With Dark Comedy [and] Humor it Seems Almost too
Coincidental That This Most Famous Dramatist of Desolation Whose Work Teams With biblical
Allusion Would be Born on the day of the Crucifixion yet Samuel [Barkley] Beckett, was Born on good Friday?
13th of April 1906 in The Affluent Village of Fox Rock eight Miles south of Dublin
Beckett was Educated at Portora royal School enniskillen Now in [Northern] [Ireland] the Alma Mater of Another great irish Playwright
Oscar Wilde Where he Excelled Academically and at Sports
He Graduated from Trinity College [Dublin] in 1927
First in his Class and was awarded [the] college's Gold medal he Seemed destined for a Glittering
Academic Career and in October 1928 he Headed to Paris for a tWo-year Exchange Fellowship at the distinguished it Called Norman Superior
his Immersion in The Parisian Literary Scene Had a Profound Impact on the Young irishman
He Became attached to [this] of Another great irish writer
James Joyce The Revered Author of Ulysses Published in 1922 and in 1929 published
His First Critical Essay on Joyce's Work-In-Progress Which Would become Fatigue ins Wake
On his Return to Dublin Beckett was Unhappy lecturing at Trinity College and resigned Out a little more Than a year
He often Said that he gave up his [Job] Because he Could not bear Teaching to Others what he, did not Know Himself
At this Point Samuel Beckett Determined to be a writer and a man of Letters in
1931 He Published A short Critical Book
Boost on the great french writer Which Brilliantly IDentified that proust was a Philosopher and his Long Novel
Was in Essence A search for the Meaning of life which rests proust Thought and Beckett agreed on the Making and Appreciation of Art
Despite The Brilliance of This Essay Beckett Would Have Many setbacks and Rejections in his attempts to [establish] Himself in the Literary World [an]
Echo of the Themes of Failure that Would so dominate, his Work he Failed to get
His First Serious attempt at a Novel Dream Affair to Middling women published Though much of it
Was Reworked Into a short Story Collection more Pricks than kicks Which came out in 1934 the
next Year he published A
Slim Volume of Poetry Echoes Bones and other Precipitates
Marked like much Work of This period With dense Erudition and Pessimism
Beckett's London Novel Murphy was Completed in 1936 This Comic Novel of Ideas is Probably his most Accessible least?
Experimental Full-Length Work Though This Didn't stop its Going Through 42
Rejections Before Finally Being Published by ravage in 1938
Beckett Had Long Suffered from Panic Attacks Anxiety and Depression often With Terrible Physical
Manifestations he Went To London in The Early 1930s to Undertake Psychoanalysis
With A famous British Analyst Wilfred Bion
The interest he Developed in Psychology and Psychiatry Showed Constantly in The asylum Scenes in Murphy and in his next Novel what
Written While Hiding out in Rural France during the Second World war
His personal Experience of Psychotherapy Emerges [Too] in His later Work much of Which Is in the Form of a Monologue
[Whereas] Speaker Gabbles in A kind of Delirium To a faceless listener much as, one might at moments in Analysis
Though Beckett's Works for Highly Nonspecific and tend not to refer Explicitly to the second World war
Or other historical Events There is little doubt that the traumas of History Deeply Scoured his Imagination
Appalled by the Treatment of his Jewish [Friends] under Nazi Occupation
Beckett Became Actively Involved in The Resistance in Paris Principally as an Information Handler
Beckett's Experience for The Wall and The Devastation he Witnessed in France Afterwards Seems to Have Contributed to a radical Change of Direction
During A return visit to Dublin in 1946 Beckett Had A Vision or Revelation of Literary Purpose Which Marks the Divide between
1930s Work Third-Person Erudite [Emissions] and A Dwindled Bewildered
First-Person Story Telling of his Mature Prose
Unlike Some of his Early Writing Which Shows the Influence of Joyce in his Wordplay and Heavy Allusion to other Literary Works the Post-war Work
Carries it Learning more Likely Making Ignorance Impotence and Failure its key Preoccupations
This Change in Direction was Accompanied by the decision to write in French There Followed between 1946 and 1950 A
Frenzy of writing Which Included much of the Work Which Samuel Beckett is now Famous Namely Waiting for godot and his great Trilogy of Novels
[Malloy] Malone dies and The unnameable
Oniton dog Order
Was written between October 1948 and January 1949 as A?
Diversion From the more Taxing as beckett's [orid] Business of Prose Composition it was eventually Staged in A small
Avant-Garde Parisian [Theatre] in January of 1953
The Plays immense Success
Generated international Controversy and wide Interest
Set on A bare Stage
Apart from a Lone Tree and One Rock With Two Characters Exchanging
Inconsequential Dialogue While Waiting at the Side of A road for a Character who never Comes
Beckett's Play Provoked Confusion and Hostility When an English Version Transferred to London in
1955 it was greeted With Whistles and Jeers of Derision
However Waiting for godot
Sukh Said A scandal and it's Arguably the most influential play of the whole of the 20th Century?
[Gato] Presents A Dark Vision of Human life Mixed with Plenty of Vaudeville Antics and
Slapstick Comedy The [Play's] Action or Inaction Seems at points Suggestive of Universal Or an Existential Condition
But at. This Place and at this Moment in Time all Mankind Is us whether
We like it or not Declares One Character did the non arrival of God oh Critics Pondered?
Suggest The Absence of God in The modern World [or] did the play Rather
Dramatize The Yearning and Sense of Incompleteness in Which, We live Most of our Lives?
Most People after all exists in A state of Anticipation or
Future-Oriented Ness Once I get the right Job or the right House or my beloved said yes Or I retire
Then I will be happy but Once Desire Or Ambition is realized
We start To want something Else The ultimate Satisfaction the God, oh who, will Give us final Fulfillment Never Arrives
Yet for all These Philosophical
Interpretations Nothing is Certain in Beckett's Work he Once Remarked that the key Word in my plays is perhaps
It May Be that Dec its greatest achievement it Is Brave Depictions not of a Pessimistic Outlook
But of A bewildered One if We leave his Plays Perplexed then this IS an Appropriate Response?
We too are Waiting for something that Never Arrives the Reassurance of A clarity of Meaning of Certainty Even The Certainty of?
Darkness
Beckett, was Almost Instinctively a Master of The Stage his next great Play Endgame in 1957 Gives us the
Enduring Image of Human beings in Dust bins
Outside The Room in Which [the] Action Takes place all Seems dead gray and Corpse in Some Sort of Post Apocalyptic Devastation
That Speaks Urgently to our Own Era of Environmental
Crisis Though A black Humour in Jaws Even Human values and meanings Seem to be Draining away
One Character Remarks as if an answer to those who
Would Turn Beckett's Work Into mere Philosophy Means Something you and I mean Something huh that's A good one at?
His Career Progressed [Becket's] Plays and Pros
Generally Became Ever More
Condensed and Minimal The Plays Would often Focus on a single Intense Image the woman buried up to
her waist in the Sand happy Days a man and Two women Fixed in Some sort of purgatorial urns
Babbling out The Story of Their Adulterous Triangle play a single illuminated Mouth Telling Stories in the Third-Person
Terrified of using the word I
Not I
Beckett Gives Us Works of Art That Offer an Experience
Not Just an Idea Or a takeaway Message he Takes Us Into the Perplexity of the modern Condition in Which the traditional
Consolations Belief in A providential Plan Or Hopes for civilizational Progress Have
Been Shattered by the Barbarism
of war and Holocaust
Yet if Beckett's Work Presents Us with Human Extremity There are Moments of Fellow Feeling of Compassion and of Exquisite Black Humor
Moreover His Writing Is marked With the most Scrupulous
Exactitude and Precision There is a shape to his chaos one Which emerges With A sort of Wintry Serenity A
Combo Let extractor to his Plays it Is this formal and Artistic achievement that allows us to cherish in Beckett's Work a, fragile
Necessary Grace
We love Bringing you These Films if You want to Help Us to Keep Bringing you Thoughtful?
Content Please Consider Supporting Us by visiting our Shop at the link on your [Screen] now
you